Magie divine,
le monde du surnaturel.
Surgi d'outre-tombe,
franchissant sans bruits portes et murs,
les fantômes font partie depuis
des siècles de notre imaginaire collectif.
Des récits d'esprit
désincarnés se retrouvent
dans tous les folklores du monde
et les histoires de fantômes
font frissonner leur auditoire
depuis la nuit des temps.
Nous ignorons ce que
nous devenons vraiment après notre mort,
mais la plupart
d'entre nous se plaisent à penser
qu'une partie de nous demeure.
Certains croient même
que nous devenons de purs esprits.
D'où la troublante hypothèse que
cette transmutation se passe parfois mal.
Les fantômes.
S'il existe autant de sortes
de fantômes que de sociétés humaines,
il y a cependant d'étonnantes similitudes
entre les fantômes
des différents pays et époques.
Quelquefois,
les fantômes sont ceux de gens célèbres
et donc aussitôt identifiables.
Ainsi, le fantôme d'Abraham Lincoln
apparaît souvent à la Maison Blanche.
Lincoln avait été profondément
bouleversé par les massacres
de la guerre de Sécession.
Peut-être est-ce ce souvenir
qui l'empêche de trouver le repos éternel.
À l'opposé de Lincoln,
certains autres
fantômes sont anonymes.
Parmi ces figures
ordinaires les plus répandues,
nous trouvons la Dame Blanche,
souvent vêtue de longues
robes blanches et vaporeuses.
En Russie,
la Roussalka est le fantôme d'une femme
noyée qui hante les rivières et les lacs.
Il existe plusieurs
explications à sa présence.
Une histoire d'amour fatale,
un accident tragique, un meurtre.
Toutes impliquent des émotions violentes
justifiant que son âme
n'ait jamais trouvé la paix.
La Roussalka n'est pas dangereuse,
même si son apparition
peut paraître effrayante.
On raconte même
qu'elle aide les voyageurs perdus
et les pêcheurs en difficulté.
Cependant, même si la rencontre
avec certains fantômes est réconfortante,
la plupart du temps
l'expérience est traumatisante.
La température de l'air descend
en flèche lorsqu'un fantôme surgit
et les témoins épouvantés
ont le souffle coupé
et les cheveux
qui se dressent sur la tête.
Les fantômes se présentent
sous diverses formes.
Ils peuvent être éthérés ou tangibles,
grotesques ou beaux,
loquaces ou muets.
Il peut s'agir d'hommes, de femmes,
d'enfants, d'animaux, de véhicules
ou même d'un bloc d'immeubles.
Quelle que soit
l'apparence qu'ils prennent,
les vivants ont la sensation d'être
en présence de quelque chose d'irréel,
qui défi les lois naturelles
et menace l'équilibre
de leur univers familier.
Quoi qu'il nous effraie,
l'inconnu nous fascine également.
La preuve en est que
notre intérêt pour les fantômes,
s'est confirmé au fil des âges.
À chaque siècle,
dans chaque société,
on trouve toujours
quelqu'un qui a croisé un fantôme.
Il n'y a pas la moindre preuve
scientifique de l'existence des fantômes,
pas plus que de leur apparition.
Pourtant, les rencontres
avec les fantômes sont et ont toujours été
l'une des expériences
surnaturelles les plus fréquentes.
Depuis la nuit des temps,
des récits détaillés témoignent
de la conviction inébranlable et sincère
de milliers de gens qui affirment
avoir bel et bien vu un spectre.
Pour reprendre ce que disait l'écrivain
anglais Samuel Johnson, voilà 200 ans,
« À ce sujet, l'intuition tend à affirmer
ce que la raison tend à infirmer. »
Au Moyen-Âge, la croyance voulait
que des fantômes s'attaquent aux vivants.
Pour les gens, rien n'était plus
terrifiant que la chevauchée fantastique.
Cette bande de cavaliers
du ciel qui déferlait implacable
sur l'Europe du Nord.
Réunis sous la férule
des dieux norvégiens incarnés,
les chevaliers de l'Apocalypse
épouvantaient ceux qui les voyaient
ou les entendaient.
La chevauchée fantastique est
une ancienne légende scandinave
et elle s'est répandue
par la suite en Europe du Nord.
La chevauchée fantastique
dérive d'une vieille croyance.
Le dieu Wotan, accompagné
de ses chasseurs avec leurs chevaux
et leurs chiens
se rendait parfois sur Terre.
Il venait enlever des âmes
et les ramener à Valhalla, le ciel.
Au cours des siècles derniers,
les apparitions de la chevauchée
fantastique se sont raréfiées
alors que le christianisme
s'étendait en Europe.
Toutefois, les cavaliers continuent à
surgir de temps à autre semant la panique
sur leur passage.
L'on raconte que si une personne
a la malchance d'entendre le galop
des chevaliers de l'Apocalypse,
ou pire, de les voir,
cela lui est fatal.
La chevauchée fantastique
est la preuve flagrante
que les fantômes ne sont pas exclusivement
des êtres humains désincarnés.
Des légendes d'attelages fantômes
et de mystérieux cavaliers
se retrouvent dans tous les folklores.
J'en déduis qu'ils sont une sorte
d'extension des fantômes proprement dits.
Après tout, nous parlons
des spectres et oublions qu'en réalité
ces spectres portent des vêtements.
Cela suppose que leurs habits soient
devenus, eux aussi, fantomatiques.
L'apparition effroyable au crépuscule
du cavalier sans tête
est répandue en Amérique du Nord
et dans toute l'Europe.
De telles visions présentes
dans les histoires de meurtre
et de vengeance,
symbolisent l'errance tragique
du fantôme incapable
de trouver la paix dans la tombe
et condamné à revivre éternellement
les souffrances de sa vie terrestre.
Beaucoup d'histoires de fantômes
n'impliquent pas que des êtres humains.
C'est le cas, par exemple,
des histoires de vaisseaux fantômes.
La plus connue
est celle du Hollandais volant,
mais il en existe bien d'autres.
Il existe d'innombrables versions
de l'histoire du Hollandais volant.
L'une d'elles se situe
au début du XIXᵉ siècle.
On raconte qu'un navire contournant
le cap Horn est pris dans une tempête.
L'équipage supplie le capitaine
de mettre le cap vers un endroit sûr,
mais il refuse
et met Dieu au défi de couler le bateau.
C'est alors
qu'un fantôme surgit sur le pont.
Devant l'équipage terrifié,
le capitaine menace de l'abattre
d'un coup de pistolet s'il ne part pas.
L'arme lui explose dans la main,
puis le spectre prononce sa malédiction.
Le capitaine est condamné à naviguer
éternellement à travers mers et océans.
Pour les marins,
apercevoir le bateau
à la dérive est un funeste présage.
Les fantômes existent dans toutes
les sociétés depuis la nuit des temps.
Les croyances qui leur sont
attachées sont étonnamment similaires.
Les morts sont censés quitter
lentement le monde terrestre
pour prendre leur juste
place parmi les esprits.
Si cette transition se passe mal,
la personne se retrouve ballottée
entre le monde des vivants
et celui des morts.
Il peut exister plusieurs
raisons à cet état intermédiaire.
Comme par exemple,
le fait que le défunt estime
n'avoir pas fini de remplir sa mission
chez les vivants.
Il n'est donc pas encore prêt à rejoindre
paisiblement le royaume des morts.
Ton heure est venue Michael.
Cela signifie que tu erreras dans
le royaume des ombres pour l'éternité.
Ainsi soit-il Michael.
Tout le monde peut devenir un fantôme.
Aucune loi ne régit le passage
de l'état de mortel à celui de fantôme.
Un fantôme est la preuve
de l'existence de la vie après la mort.
Il peut faire l'objet d'une apparition
ou se manifester par des impressions,
des empreintes figées
dans le temps et l'espace.
Au fond,
nous croyons aux fantômes
parce que nous avons besoin d'eux
pour prouver la survie de notre âme.
Pour apaiser nos craintes,
sur notre propre monde.
Les fantômes surgissent
tour à tour pour nous conseiller
nous avertir, nous consoler.
Ils valident nos actes
dans l'univers des vivants
et nous rassurent en nous montrant qu'il
existe autre chose après la mort physique.
Chaque être humain a pour
mission de progresser spirituellement
parmi ses semblables.
S'il ne le fait pas de son vivant,
il est condamné
à le faire après sa mort.
C'est pourquoi je ne peux
pas trouver le repos,
je ne peux rester,
je ne peux m'attarder nulle part.
Les fantômes peuvent également
aider les vivants à retrouver leur voie
grâce à la sagesse que leur confère
l'expérience de leur vie terrestre.
Ainsi, Charles Dickens a vu lui-même
des fantômes qui ont joué par la suite
un rôle primordial
dans ses œuvres.
Dans l'un
de ces livres les plus célèbres,
Les Contes de Noël,
des fantômes prennent
en charge Scrooge, le héros,
et l'aident à changer de vie
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard.
Les fantômes qui
se manifestent à Scrooge sont lestés
par de lourdes chaînes
qui les rattachent à notre monde.
Dickens n'est pas
le premier à avoir eu cette idée.
L'image du fantôme enchaîné
remonte à des récits lointains.
La toute première histoire de fantôme,
du grec Athénodore, décrit déjà
le bruit des chaînes raclant le sol.
L'histoire d'Athénodore
correspond sans doute
à la toute première enquête
sérieusement menée sur les fantômes.
Elle a été reprise
par Pline le Jeune, l'historien romain,
et nous est parvenue comme le premier
cas connu de fantôme enchaîné.
L'histoire d'Athénodore
est semble-t-il véridique.
Elle s'inspire de sa propre expérience.
Les événements se situent
en Grèce, il y a plus de 2000 ans.
Ils ont lieu dans une maison
réputée pour être hantée
par le fantôme bruyant
d'un vieil homme torturé.
Profitant du loyer très bas
et indifférent aux avertissements
des précédents locataires,
Athénodore emménage.
Très vite, il entend le bruit nocturne
des chaînes qui s'entrechoquent,
il voit même
apparaître le fameux spectre.
Au début,
Athénodore tente de l'ignorer,
mais sa curiosité est aussitôt éveillée.
Il comprend que le fantôme
essaie de communiquer avec lui.
Alors, il le suit dans la nuit.
Le lendemain matin,
Athénodore va chercher le magistrat local
pour qu'il examine
l'endroit de l'apparition du fantôme.
Athénodore est certain que le fantôme
a une bonne raison de hanter la maison.
Il craint que l'esprit du vieil homme ne
dispose pas d'un endroit décent où reposer
et pense que la maison
ne retrouvera son calme
que lorsqu'il aura résolu l'énigme
de cette apparition douloureuse.
Dans la nuit, Athénodore jette
des feuilles à l'endroit de l'apparition.
Selon lui, c'est là
que réside la clé du mystère.
Au matin,
en creusant à l'endroit indiqué,
on découvre
les restes d'un corps.
Les ossements sont enterrés lors
d'une cérémonie en bonne et due forme,
et le fantôme n'apparaît plus jamais.
Désormais,
le vieil homme peut reposer en paix.
Cependant, il est bien difficile de
satisfaire si aisément tous les fantômes.
Certains n'apparaissent
que pour délivrer une sentence de mort.
Ces messagers de la mort apparaissent
pratiquement dans toutes les sociétés
et leur funeste
sentence est irrévocable.
Le message peut être délivré
par une lueur dans le regard,
l'écho d'une belle chanson
ou d'une plainte interminable,
mais sa signification est tout de
suite interceptée par son destinataire.
Le fantôme venant annoncer
la mort est sans aucun doute
celui que l'on rencontre
le plus fréquemment.
La banshee des légendes irlandaises
et écossaises en est un exemple.
Les banshees sont traditionnellement
associées aux fées de la forêt.
À l'opposé de leurs sœurs,
elles peuvent être maléfiques.
La banshee est une légende
celtique, surtout irlandaise.
L'apparition d'une banshee
cause toujours un traumatisme
puisque ses hurlements annoncent
généralement une mort prochaine.
Le peu de gens
qui ont eu une telle vision,
affirment que la banshee
peut être indifféremment,
vieille ou jeune.
Parfois,
elle a été aperçue au bord
d'une rivière en train de laver du linge.
Ce linge est censé appartenir
à une personne qui va bientôt mourir.
En 1318, le chevalier normand
Richard de Clare rencontre sa banshee.
Sur la route qui le conduit
en Écosse où il doit livrer une bataille,
il aperçoit au bord
d'un fleuve une femme effrayante.
Richard la regarde sans crainte laver
des monceaux de linge ensanglantés.
Puis fasciné,
il finit par lui demander
à qui appartiennent ces vêtements.
« À vous »,
lui répond-elle.
Richard s'en va,
persuadé que la femme est folle.
Pourtant, le lendemain,
il git sur le champ de bataille
dans une mare de sang.
De vieilles familles
irlandaises comme les O'Brian,
les O'Malley, les O'Rourke
et les O'Donnell ont leurs propres
banshees qui s'érigent un peu
comme leurs anges gardiens.
Elles peuvent pleurer la mort
d'un membre de la famille,
tout comme elles peuvent
célébrer l'arrivée d'un nouveau venu.
Même quand des individus
s'exilent loin de leur patrie
leurs banshees
continuent à les surveiller.
En Amérique du Nord et en Australie,
la mort de certains membres
de la famille est souvent annoncée
par ces mêmes plaintes familières.
Pendant des siècles,
l'apparition d'une banshee a souvent
été annonciatrice d'une mort imminente.
Les membres d'une famille qui entendaient
ces lamentations savaient d'ores et déjà
que l'un d'entre eux allait mourir.
Aujourd'hui,
ce sont ceux qui voient l'apparition qui
sont eux-mêmes condamnés à trépasser.
Peu de fantômes prennent
plus à cœur les affaires des vivants
que les spectres japonais.
Les fantômes japonais
peuvent prendre diverses formes.
Ils sont généralement vêtus de blanc.
Le blanc étant là-bas la couleur du deuil,
étroitement lié à la mort
car décédés dans de mauvaises
conditions, ils se présentent ébouriffés.
C'est logique
puisqu'on devient fantôme
à cause d'une passion quelconque
qui nous empêche d'entrer sereinement
dans le royaume des morts.
Aussi longtemps
que cette passion existe,
elle nous obsède.
On ne pense plus à laver ni à peigner
nos cheveux qui deviennent hirsutes.
En ce moment, les fantômes, y compris
au Japon font partie du sexe faible.
Les émotions fortes
sont généralement attribuées aux femmes,
réputées pour être moins
lucide que les hommes.
Au Japon,
les fantômes sont omniprésents,
ils s'immiscent partout
et peuvent causer de grands malheurs.
Même si un riche passé spirituel
et la fusion
de plusieurs religions
peuvent justifier
la variété des fantômes japonais,
ils n'expliquent pas pourquoi les fantômes
sont si actifs dans la vie quotidienne.
Les fantômes japonais sont
dotés de certains pouvoirs
que les spectres
occidentaux n'ont pas.
Eux, par exemple, peuvent tuer.
Dans la culture occidentale,
un fantôme peut inspirer
à quelqu'un d'autre l'idée de tuer.
Le fantôme d'Hamlet, par exemple,
essaie d'amener le jeune prince
à tuer Claudius.
Un fantôme japonais
n'agirait pas ainsi.
Il reviendrait et tuerait lui-même
son ennemi en le rendant fou
ou en l'amenant au suicide
ou simplement
en l'enveloppant d'un souffle fatal.
Dans la célèbre
histoire de Yuki-onna,
la dame des neiges,
Minokichi et son compagnon
sont pris dans une tempête
alors qu'ils étaient
sortis couper du bois.
Tant bien que mal, ils gagnent un abri de
fortune où ils décident de passer la nuit.
Peu après, la porte s'ouvre
et Minokichi est horrifié
à la vue d'un fantôme.
C'est la dame des neiges qui se dirige
vers son ami et d'un souffle fatal,
lui ôte la vie.
Minokichi, pétrifié
de terreur, attend lui aussi sa fin.
Seulement, au dernier moment,
frappée par la beauté de Minokichi,
la dame des neiges
décide de l'épargner
à condition de ne raconter
à personne son aventure.
Elle jure de le tuer
s'il trahit son serment.
Puis disparaît dans la nuit glaciale.
Les années passent
et Minokichi tient sa promesse.
Un jour, il rencontre
la belle Yuki, qu'il épouse.
Ils engendrent trois fils
et vivent heureux tous ensemble.
Puis un soir,
en regardant sa femme,
Minokichi est assailli
par la vision de la dame des neiges.
Brusquement, les souvenirs
le ramène à cette terrible nuit de neige,
il raconte toute l'histoire à sa femme.
Trop tard,
il comprend que celle-ci
n'est autre que Yuki-onna.
Redevenue fantôme, elle se prépare
à le punir d'avoir trahi son serment.
De nouveau,
au dernier moment, elle se ravise.
Puisque si elle tue Minokichi,
qui s'occupera de leurs
trois jeunes enfants ?
En tant que fantôme,
elle en est incapable.
Aussi, s'enfuit-elle dans la nuit, où
elle restera à jamais la dame des neiges.
Les illustrations de fantômes
tiennent une place importante
dans la culture populaire japonaise.
Au XVIIIᵉ et XIXᵉ siècle,
les ouvrages sur ce thème sont accueillis
avec enthousiasme dans les foyers japonais
et l'engouement pour
les gravures monstrueuses devient tel
que le gouvernement finit
par interdire leur publication.
Il existe en Extrême-Orient une longue
tradition de peinture spectrale.
L'une des raisons à cela
selon la vieille école
de peinture chinoise,
est que certaines œuvres remontent
à plusieurs siècles avant Jésus-Christ.
Un bon peintre peut
illustrer des êtres vivants,
mais seul un artiste exceptionnel saurait
peindre des esprits que par définition
peu de gens et généralement pas
le peintre lui-même n'ont pu voir.
Dans ces conditions,
les représenter
fidèlement devient très difficile.
Un ancien jeu japonais montre
bien l'importance des fantômes
dans la culture populaire.
Prisé à l'origine par les guerriers
samouraï pour prouver leur courage,
les Cent histoire devient un jeu
courant au XVIIIᵉ et XIXᵉ siècle.
On y joue la nuit, l'été,
en formant un groupe
autour de cent bougies allumées.
Tour à tour chaque personne
raconte une histoire terrifiante.
À la fin de chaque récit,
on souffle une bougie et l'atmosphère
devient de plus en plus oppressante.
Le jeu est interdit aux enfants.
Seuls les joueurs les plus
courageux restent jusqu'au bout.
La terreur ambiante
atteint son paroxysme
lorsqu'on éteint la dernière bougie
et qu'un fantôme apparaît.
D'après les croyances japonaises,
c'est le fantôme malheureux
dont personne ne s'occupe,
qui peut
revenir déranger les vivants.
Ainsi,
pour éviter les ennuis,
il est préférable de bien respecter
le rituel qui assure le passage paisible
d'une âme au royaume des morts.
On utilise des bougies
pour assurer le passage dans l'au-delà.
Partout dans le monde,
une bougie allumée
est censée repousser les démons.
Chasser les mauvais esprits
et protéger l'âme du défunt.
Dans toutes les cultures,
il est considéré comme sage et bienséant
de traiter les morts avec respect.
Dans l'Irlande du XIXᵉ siècle,
on exprime son respect
en touchant le corps d'un défunt.
D'autres rituels entourent
le deuil et les funérailles.
Faire la toilette d'un mort
a été l'apanage de la culture européenne
pendant des siècles.
Partout, la tradition veut que
les vivants fassent de leur mieux
pour assurer
la survie de l'âme du défunt.
On a longtemps considéré que les miroirs,
puissants dans la pensée mystique,
pouvaient perturber une âme
affaiblie par l'approche de la mort.
Dans certaines régions d'Europe,
on couvre par précaution
toutes les surfaces réfléchissantes.
Ce sont les minutes qui suivent le décès
qui peuvent se révéler dangereuses.
Les fantômes et les mauvais
esprits menacent alors le défunt
et la famille proche.
Aussi, des amulettes fétiches
et objets de culte sont-ils
utilisés en guise de protection.
Ces anciens rituels demeurent
présents dans de nombreuses cultures
et font partie du folklore
et des superstitions locales.
Dans les basses terres d'Écosse,
on promène encore
des bougies au-dessus des corps
lors d'une cérémonie issue
des croyances pré-chrétiennes.
Personne ne souhaite qu'un fantôme
revienne hanter son ancienne maison,
et des rituels
sont destinés à empêcher cela.
Le corps doit sortir
de la demeure, les pieds devant,
et de préférence par la porte de derrière.
L'acheminement du corps vers
la tombe doit être lent et solennel.
Il peut être jalonné de pauses
à des endroits ayant une signification
particulière pour le défunt,
afin de lui donner la possibilité
de faire ses adieux à ces lieux.
L'une des coutumes
funéraires les plus répandues
consistant à placer les objets
fétiches du défunt dans sa tombe,
est certes destinée à le consoler,
mais surtout à protéger les vivants.
En effet, tout ce qui pourra
apaiser l'âme du défunt dans l'au-delà,
le dissuadera de revenir
hanté les lieux de sa vie terrestre.
Ainsi, les Égyptiens qui
redoutaient les fantômes,
prenaient soin
de laisser des victuailles aux morts
et consacraient assez d'énergie
à inventer de nouvelles amulettes
qui permettraient à l'âme d'effectuer
paisiblement son voyage dans l'au-delà.
Parfois, des objets en fer sont censés
empêcher le fantôme de s'échapper.
Le fer est lourd à déplacer
et selon certaines croyances,
les fantômes ne peuvent passer à travers.
Selon les anciens,
les âmes de personnes n'ayant pas été
enterrées convenablement ne peuvent
connaître le repos éternel.
Elles reviennent
sur Terre pour hanter les vivants.
Les coutumes funéraires
diffèrent autour du monde,
mais toutes s'accordent sur le principe
qu'un enterrement dans les règles
est nécessaire pour le repos d'une âme.
Autrefois, on prenait
des précautions particulières
pour exhumer les personnes
décédées tragiquement.
Puisqu'en général,
c'étaient elles qui avait du mal
à trouver la paix outre-tombe.
Les criminels et les sorciers aussi,
avaient droit à un rituel spécial.
On les enterrait à la croisée
des chemins pour embrouiller les esprits
et les empêcher de rentrer chez eux.
On empalait les prétendus vampires
sur une pique plantée en plein cœur,
pour mettre un terme
à leurs errances nocturnes.
Dans la plupart des cultures,
un cimetière est par définition
un endroit calme et paisible.
Des clôtures en fer tiennent
les mauvais esprits à distance
et empêchent
les fantômes de s'échapper.
Les arbres également sont importants.
En Chine, on dit que les cyprès apportent
de l'énergie aux âmes des défunts.
En Europe, les ifs,
outre qu'ils symbolisent la régénération,
ont de longues et profondes
racines qui sont censées
maintenir les morts dans leurs tombes.
Les lourdes pierres
tombales ont la même fonction.
Même après les funérailles,
le danger n'est pas écarté.
Malgré toutes les précautions,
il est possible que des fantômes
tourmentés essaient d'aller chez eux.
Pour prévenir pareil problème,
le cortège funèbre peut
prendre une route inhabituelle
pour aller de la maison au cimetière,
afin d'essayer de brouiller les pistes.
Dans les cas extrêmes,
on peut repeindre des portes
ou même des maisons entières.
Beaucoup de pratiques superstitieuses
sont destinées à décourager les fantômes,
comme par exemple le fer à cheval placé
sur la porte, censé les tenir à distance.
Ou le sel déposé sur le seuil.
L'idéal est une rivière tumultueuse
qu'aucun fantôme ne peut franchir.
Le port de vêtements noirs
également rend la personne en deuil
plus difficile
à localiser par les esprits.
Pour ceux qui n'ont pas
réussi à écarter les fantômes,
il faut savoir que l'apparition
d'un revenant n'est pas forcément néfaste.
Parfois, au contraire,
ce retour peut être source de joie.
Les apparitions sur le lit
de mort sont un cas très intéressant.
On les retrouve dans
les cultures du monde entier.
Généralement,
il s'agit de fantômes
de défunts venant chercher le mourant.
Les visiteurs spectraux
peuvent être des parents,
des amis, des enfants,
des époux ou des amants,
bref, quelqu'un que
le mourant aura plaisir à reconnaître.
Ils peuvent apparaître au
mourant deux semaines avant son décès,
s'il est atteint d'une longue maladie.
Ou seulement quelques
heures avant son trépas.
Ils sont pour lui
une grande source de réconfort.
Quand ils surgissent,
le mourant peut enfin trouver la paix,
surtout si jusque-là,
il souffrait beaucoup.
Généralement,
les personnes présentes dans la chambre
n'ont pas conscience de ces apparitions.
Le mourant peut dire,
un tel ou un tel est venu me chercher,
sans que quiconque
ne perçoive quoi que ce soit.
Souvent, le mourant voit
des scènes d'une grande beauté,
qui préfigurent le paradis à venir.
Comme de beaux jardins,
de riantes prairies ou de luxueux palais.
Les visiteurs présents dans
ces scènes idylliques sont en général
des êtres chers, déjà décédés,
venus chercher l'âme du mourant
pour l'escorter au paradis.
Croire que les gens ont peur
des fantômes est une fausse idée.
Pour la plupart, il est rassurant
et même encourageant de savoir
qu'un être aimé les attend
au royaume des ombres
et qu'une vie
heureuse leur est réservée.
Les fantômes ne sont pas
seulement là pour aider les mourants
à effectuer leur
passage de la vie à la mort.
Ils leur servent également de guide
dans l'au-delà et adoucissent leur départ,
en les aidant à se repérer
dans leur nouveau royaume.
Comme les visiteurs
des derniers instants,
la plupart de ces fantômes sont
supposés être des membres de la famille,
et les retrouvailles dans
l'au-delà sont donc joyeuses.
Ces fantômes
spontanément réconfortants
et plein de sollicitude sont une chose,
mais il existe aussi
bien sûr, les fantômes errants.
Ceux qui sont
associés à un endroit précis,
qu'il semble incapable de quitter,
où ils apparaissent régulièrement.
Ils hantent ainsi
les remparts d'un château,
les couloirs d'un palais, d'une abbaye
ou d'un tout autre lieu familier.
Souvent, ils semblent
murés dans leurs propres soucis.
Si quelqu'un les aborde,
ils ne répondent pas
et poursuivent
leur chemin, l'air triste,
visiblement obsédés
par leurs problèmes personnels.
Depuis le XVIᵉ siècle,
le château de Clonony,
en Irlande, est hanté
par le long spectre décharné
d'un noble qui flotte régulièrement
à l'intérieur et
à l'extérieur des remparts.
L'unique indice sur son identité
est un caveau très simple,
situé juste au-delà
de l'enceinte du château.
Là, sont enterrés
Mary et Elizabeth Boleyn,
cousines de l'infortunée
épouse d'Henry VIII, Anne.
Personne ne sait
comment elles sont mortes,
ni pourquoi on
les a enterrées ensemble.
On pense que le noble devenu
fantôme a peut-être joué un rôle
dans leur mystérieux décès.
Les fantômes errants hantent
aussi les pages de notre littérature.
Ainsi,
William Shakespeare,
le grand dramaturge anglais, introduit
volontiers des fantômes dans ses œuvres.
Surtout dans ses pièces historiques,
comme Richard III et Jules César.
Dans ces tragédies,
les fantômes jouent un rôle essentiel.
Celui du père d'Hamlet
est l'instigateur du drame.
Alors que dans Macbeth,
c'est celui du général Banquo
qui, implacablement,
fait plonger Macbeth dans la folie.
Les tours de conte de fées
du château de Glamis
cachent de sombres secrets.
Lieu de naissance de la reine mère,
c'est le plus vieux château
habité d'Écosse et le plus célèbre.
En 1535, la belle Lady Glamis
périt sur le bûcher pour avoir, dit-on,
tenté d'empoisonner le roi d'Écosse.
On aperçoit toujours
son fantôme qui erre éternellement
dans les jardins qu'elle aimait tant.
La royauté est bien représentée
parmi les fantômes britanniques,
et plusieurs rois
et reines semblent incapables
de trouver le repos dans leur tombe.
L'un des plus célèbres
est celui de l'infortunée Anne Boleyn,
femme d'Henri VIII
et mère de la reine Élisabeth 1ère.
L'incapacité d'Anne
à enfanter un héritier mâle
mit un terme à son règne et à sa vie.
Pour permettre
à Henri VIII de se remarier,
la jeune et belle Anne fut emprisonnée
dans la sinistre Tour de Londres.
Accusée d'adultère,
de sorcellerie et de trahison,
elle fut décapitée en l'an 1536.
Depuis, son fantôme a été aperçu
dans cinq des endroits où elle a vécu,
y compris le dernier,
la Tour de Londres.
Là, les hallebardiers
l'ont vu sous diverses formes.
Parfois, Anne apparaît simplement
comme une lumière étincelante
et souvent, son spectre
erre dans l'enceinte du château.
Ses apparitions
les plus spectaculaires sont celles
où elle se matérialise
en une silhouette furtive,
portant sa tête sous son bras.
Cette scène effrayante est l'une
des plus célèbres visions fantomatiques.
Le fantôme d'Anne Boleyn
apparaît également en d'autres lieux.
On dit qu'elle hante Blickling Hall,
le château de son enfance,
ainsi que celui de
Hampton Court, son préféré.
Là, son fantôme semble plus à l'aise.
On l'aperçoit rarement décapitée,
mais plutôt flânant tranquillement
dans les cours
et les jardins où elle fût heureuse.
Certains bâtiments deviennent célèbres
grâce aux fantômes qui les hantent.
C'est le cas de
la Maison Blanche en Amérique.
Abraham Lincoln, qui
devint plus tard un fantôme très actif,
a été fasciné par le spiritisme.
Désireux de communiquer
avec son fils défunt,
il fit appel à plusieurs médiums.
Nous ignorons s'il a jamais réussi
à entrer en contact avec son fils,
mais les messages reçus de l'au-delà
pendant ces longues séances
auraient contribué à le persuader
de la nécessité d'abolir l'esclavage.
Les mediums deviennent
populaires à la fin des années 1840,
période marquant
l'avènement du spiritisme.
Cette vague balaya l'Amérique
et franchit même l'Atlantique
pour gagner l'Angleterre.
Les médiums sont notamment très
sollicités pendant la guerre de Sécession
par les familles des soldats tués,
soucieuses d'être rassurées
sur le sort de leurs
enfants dans l'au-delà.
Ces séances finissent par
devenir un véritable phénomène de mode
et les meilleurs médiums sont débordés.
Des gens qui,
jusque-là, savaient tout juste
qu'il existait un monde spirituel,
essayent désormais chaque nuit
d'entrer en contact avec les morts.
Une séance est une réunion,
enfin une tentative pour entrer
en communication avec les morts.
Les gens se rassemblent
autour d'une table avec un médium.
Cela se passe généralement
dans un endroit sombre.
Les gens imposent leurs
mains au-dessus de la table
et quand le médium atteint
un état de conscience approprié,
le phénomène commence à se produire.
Il peut bien sûr y avoir une lévitation,
des vibrations de la table,
un déplacement d'objets
ou d'étranges apparitions.
Les morts se font parfois entendre
ou même se matérialisent sous
la forme présumée du fantôme lui-même.
Un médium peut obtenir
un message direct d'un esprit
ou bien entrer en transe,
afin que l'esprit s'exprime à travers lui.
De nombreuses tricheries ont été
dénoncées au XIXᵉ et même au XXᵉ siècle,
mais certains cas
intéressants demeurent inexpliqués.
Le résultat
des séances est imprévisible
et c'est cela qui fascine les gens.
Une fois que le contact
avec l'au-delà est établi,
tout peut arriver.
Des bouquets de fleurs exotiques couvertes
de rosée peuvent surgir de nulle part,
de même que des instruments de musique
ou les objets préférés du défunt.
Lincoln lui-même voit un piano
s'élever tout seul dans la pièce.
Peut-être est-ce sa réceptivité naturelle
au spirituel qui permit à Lincoln
de vivre deux expériences
prémonitoires de sa mort.
Avant son élection en 1860,
il est alarmé à la vue d'une image
dédoublée de lui-même dans son miroir.
Juste dix jours
avant son assassinat en 1865,
il fait un rêve intense
qui devait se concrétiser.
Il écrit dans son journal.
« Je me suis couché tard
et j'ai très vite commencé à rêver. »
« Un silence sépulcral
semblait m'entourer et m'envelopper. »
« Puis j'ai entendu des sanglots étouffés,
comme si des gens pleuraient. »
« Alors, j'ai cru quitter mon lit
pour descendre l'escalier. »
« Là, le silence était troublé
par les mêmes lamentations. »
« Mais les affligés étaient invisibles. »
« Je suis allé de pièce en pièce,
sans voir quiconque, »
« mais les mêmes sanglots
me poursuivaient. »
« Déterminé à découvrir la cause
de ce mystérieux phénomène, »
« j'ai poursuivi mes investigations
jusqu'à la chambre du fond »
« où je suis entré. »
« Devant moi, sur le catafalque, reposait
un corps drapé dans son linceul. »
« Autour de lui, des soldats
en faction, faisant office de gardes »
« ainsi qu'une foule de gens. »
« Certains regardaient
tristement le défunt, »
« d'autres pleuraient. »
« "Qui est mort à la Maison Blanche ?" »
« demandais-je à l'un des soldats. »
« "Le Président", me répondit-il.
Il a été assassiné. »
« Les lamentations
qui lui firent écho me réveillèrent. »
« Je n'ai plus dormi cette nuit,
et bien qu'il s'agisse d'un rêve, »
« j'en demeure étrangement perturbé. »
Le corps du Président assassiné
est ramené chez lui à Springfield,
dans l'Illinois, et exhumé.
Même le convoi funéraire est
le théâtre d'événements surnaturels.
On prétend que chaque année,
à minuit, l'heure de sa mort,
un train fantôme refait le même trajet.
Sur son passage,
toutes les horloges
et les montres s'arrêtent.
Le convoi progresse silencieusement
et n'atteint jamais sa destination.
Plusieurs hôtes de la Maison Blanche
ont rapporté avoir vu le fantôme
du Président assassiné.
La Première dame d'Amérique,
Lady Grace Coolidge,
le Président Harry Truman
et le Premier ministre britannique,
Winston Churchill,
reçurent la visite du fantôme.
La reine Wilhelmine des Pays-Bas
raconte ainsi sa rencontre
avec le fantôme de Lincoln.
Une nuit, alors qu'elle est
en visite chez le Président Roosevelt,
à la Maison Blanche,
elle lit la Bible dans sa chambre
quand on frappe à sa porte.
Elle l'ouvre et se trouve
face à un grand homme barbu,
coiffé d'un chapeau haut-de-forme
et habillé à la mode du XIXᵉ siècle.
C'est seulement le lendemain matin
qu'elle prend conscience
qu'il s'agissait du fantôme de Lincoln.
Après la mort de son mari,
Mary Todd Lincoln
vint sous un faux nom
consulter le photographe
médium William Mumler.
Le cliché montre la silhouette floue
du défunt Président à côté de sa femme.
Le bostonien William Mumler,
est à l'avant-garde d'une nouvelle mode.
En 1861, il développe une pellicule
qui semble contenir un cliché de fantôme.
L'idée est née et bientôt d'autres
photographes suivent sa trace.
Dès que l'appareil
photographique fut inventé,
on s'empressa d'essayer
de prendre en photo les revenants.
C'était là le genre de preuve
que tout le monde attendait.
Puis enfin, la curiosité
des gens allait être satisfaite.
On obtient un nombre
impressionnant de clichés spectraux.
En gros,
les choses se déroulent ainsi.
La personne prend la pose
et le photographe opère.
En apparence,
ils sont seuls dans la pièce,
mais lorsqu'on développe la pellicule,
une ombre floue
se dessine dans un coin du cliché,
où l'on peut discerner un visage.
C'est toujours et encore la même figure
qui apparaît sur tous les clichés.
Pourtant, beaucoup l'identifieront
comme étant le parent qu'elles ont perdu.
Cela ne semble troubler personne.
Même quand un célèbre photographe
français est confondu comme escroc,
beaucoup de gens continuent à croire
que grâce à une photographie,
ils détiennent la preuve tangible
de la survie de leurs proches
dans l'au-delà.
Peu de ces photographies spontanées
de fantômes sont convaincantes.
L'une des rares exceptions
est celle du fantôme de Greenwich.
Il s'agit d'un cliché
pris dans un endroit connu,
par une personne connue,
à une date bien déterminée,
et qui montre apparemment
un spectre dans un escalier.
L'appareil photographique
n'est pas le seul moyen employé
pour tenter de prouver
scientifiquement l'existence des fantômes.
Le plus connu demeure la planchette.
La méthode consiste à poser
sa main sur une rondelle en bois,
où est fixé un crayon.
Ce dernier se met alors
à écrire automatiquement
le message dicté par les esprits.
Ce mode de communication ne subit
aucune intervention humaine extérieure.
Au XIXᵉ et au début du XXᵉ siècle,
on rivalise d'imagination
pour inventer de nouveaux moyens,
du plus simple au plus sophistiqué,
afin d'entrer en contact avec
les esprits sans passer par un médium.
Aucun de ces procédés
ne surpasse le jeu du Ouija.
Le nom de ce jeu est en fait
dérivé du « oui » français
et du « oui » allemand, « ja ».
Une fois de plus, l'idée consiste
à poser des questions aux esprits
avec l'espoir
qu'ils envoient un signe quelconque,
en direction d'une lettre ou d'un chiffre.
Ou plus simplement,
en répondant, oui
ou non à la question posée.
De nombreux sceptiques affirment
que les fantômes sont une pure invention.
Force est d'admettre
qu'au sens scientifique du terme,
on ne détient
aucune preuve de leur existence.
Toutefois, nous disposons
d'innombrables témoignages remontants
à plus de 2000 ans.
Est-il raisonnable de penser que tous
ces gens qui ont témoigné affabulaient ?
Le château de Cloughan
est l'un des sites privilégiés
des apparitions spectrales.
Située à Banagher, en Irlande,
il fut habité pendant plus de 1000 ans
et a été le témoin
de nombreux épisodes sanglants.
Les envahisseurs normands
en sont chassés en 1336
par Eoghan O'Madden, le grand chef
irlandais qui s'y installe avec son clan.
Deux siècles plus tard, les O'Madden
doivent de nouveau défendre leur terres,
cette fois contre l'envahisseur anglais.
En 1595, en effet,
le château est attaqué
par l'armée de la reine Elisabeth.
Dans la bataille,
200 personnes périssent en un seul jour.
J'ai commencé par le haut,
puis j'ai descendu l'escalier
en spirale en fermant les portes à clé
et au fur et à mesure.
Arrivé en bas,
j'ai claqué la porte d'entrée, comme ça.
Une silhouette argentée est apparue,
à la seconde où la porte s'est fermée,
j'ai entendu un hurlement effroyable.
Puis le silence est revenu.
Je me tenais à l'endroit où
46 personnes ont été massacrées en 1595,
précipitées depuis le haut du donjon.
En fait, j'étais debout sur leurs tombes.
Parfois, les fantômes de Cloughan
ne se contentent pas de hurler.
Le gardien a constaté que chaque
semaine, dans la nuit du mercredi
et celle du dimanche,
un coussin du banc
à dossier pivotait sur la droite.
Nous n'avons trouvé
aucune explication à cela.
Le gardien a pris
des photos du coussin et du banc,
puis ne s'en est plus préoccupé.
Quand on a développé le cliché,
il y avait une silhouette
agenouillée devant le banc,
sa main droite posée
sur le bord droit du coussin.
Les expériences traumatiques
laissent une empreinte sur les lieux
où elles se produisent.
C'est une sorte de courant
énergétique que l'on peut percevoir
si l'on a une nature réceptive
ou si les circonstances s'y prêtent.
Au-delà de cela,
je pense qu'après leur mort,
les gens continuent
à exister sur un autre plan,
et que dans certains contextes
et à certains endroits,
ils peuvent nous apparaître
comme cela s'est produit dans ce château.
Il me paraît certain
que les êtres humains ne meurent pas
et qu'ils peuvent
revenir s'ils le désirent.
À ma mort,
je ne vais pas disparaitre.
Je sais que si un jour quelqu'un
vient saccager cette pièce
et que je m'y trouve sous forme d'esprit,
j'essaierai de lui faire sentir
qu'il a tort d'agir ainsi.
Qui sait, peut-être comprendra-t-il.